hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd
and skin care user we talk a lot about how to use
your products but today i wanted to talk about how
not to use your products so i'm going to go
through some of the mistakes i see people
making when using their products and why you
shouldn't do that if you like talking nerdy
about beauty click the like the subscribe and the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
first the dropper on the face i see this a lot
on social media and i guess it looks really cool
but the issue is that droppers
aren't meant to be used that way
and what i mean by that is the
preservative system inside the product
isn't designed to let you use it that way so
preservatives are put into a product to stop
microbes like bacteria and fungi from growing too
much if you have too much bacteria and fungi in
there you can end up with really nasty infections
when you put that product back on your face
the way that they test a preservative system
is by mixing the product with fungi or bacteria
and then waiting and seeing how much fungi and
bacteria grow a good preservative system will
actually decrease the amount of fungi and bacteria
will actually kill anything that's been added
with a bad preservative system the bacteria and
fungi might just not change or they might even be
allowed to grow with challenge testing the fungi
or bacteria actually gets reintroduced so part
way through the testing they chuck in a bit more
so this is meant to simulate what would happen
if you dug into a jar with a dirty finger or you
touched a wand to your skin or lips and it wasn't
completely clean if the product passes this
challenge testing that means that you can put
it in a riskier type of packaging so like a jar
or a product that has an applicator wand and in
general products want to minimize the amount of
preservatives they use they want to put in just
enough to do the job preservatives tend to be
irritating and allergenic if you have too much
they are some of the more irritating and
allergenic ingredients that you find in cosmetics
so if you're touching the dropper to your
face you're making the preservative system
do something that it wasn't meant to
do it's not in its job description
the second mistake is saving up the serum
from your sheet masks this is a similar
issue again you're making the preservative
system do a job that it wasn't meant to do
single-use foil sachets are considered one of
the safest types of packaging they're meant
to be single used there's no expected shelf life
after you open it there's not even air going into
it like there is in a tube where you dispense them
and then a little bit of air gets sucked back in
the preservative systems for these tend to be the
weakest so if you're saving up the extra source
and keeping it for a week or so then again you're
making it do a job that it wasn't meant to do
it is possible that the preservative system can
stand up to this but really that product was
only ever intended to be used a few hours after
opening not a few days or a week or a month after
you've opened up the sachet of the air then there
are lots of micros in the air and cosmetics are
really good food for microbes it's watery there's
lots of nutrients for them to grow sheet masks
are usually at a nice skin friendly and microbe
friendly ph you're also probably keeping it at
room temperature which is warm enough for these
microbes to usually reproduce really quickly and
so you are risking contamination again with the
bacteria talk getting moisture into your products
water is really good for microbial growth if you
have a cosmetic product then generally you will
need to have a preservative if it's got water in
it if you want it to last for longer than like a
week if there's extra water going into a product
then this can lead to trouble the worst situation
is if there's a product that has a big opening
like a hair mask in a jar that you take into the
shower and water literally drips into it if you're
adding extra water a lot of the time this sits on
top and so this doesn't get enough preservative
that extra water will be a really good place for
bacteria and microbes to start growing even if
you just start using a product in a damp bathroom
after you showered there might be enough moisture
there to cause problems so for example if you get
condensation inside the container inside like
the walls of a jar for example then bacteria and
microbes can start growing there so if you want
to avoid this water contamination if you go into
the shower then it's a good idea to scoop out the
product and put it into a little container like
one of these caps that you get from a whole
bunch of different products if you're putting
on skincare in the bathroom let your bathroom air
out and dry out a bit before you start doing your
skincare routine or you can use them in a
different room maybe your bedroom instead
transferring your products into a different
container i've been guilty of this one in the past
it can be okay but you have to be really
careful firstly the container has to be
very clean the preservative system in
the product might not be designed to
deal with whatever dust or bits of
cardboard or whatever's inside the container
some containers are also incompatible with certain
products glass is generally okay but plastics can
react with preservatives or active ingredients
or different solvents inside the product
sunscreen ingredients for example can soak into
plastics and so that means you have less of the
sunscreen ingredients in your sunscreen they can
also just dissolve the container so if you have a
really clean container if you're only putting the
product in there for a very short amount of time
or if you know that that container was designed
for that purpose then it can be okay you can also
test the container with the product so you can
smear it on and look for visible changes but
sometimes the changes aren't that obvious so just
keep that in mind when you're using that product
not applying enough sunscreen i see a little
goes a long way all the time in sunscreen
reviews the problem is sunscreen is like paint
you are trying to hide your skin from the sun
sunscreen is tested at two milligrams per square
centimeter to get that spf label on the bottle
you can apply less sunscreen but the
spf will generally go down linearly
so that means if you apply half the
amount then you get about half the spf
but you run into more issues if you apply less
than half the amount so your skin isn't flat it's
microscopically bumpy there are lots of hills
and valleys so when you apply the sunscreen you
fill in the valleys first and if you don't have
enough sunscreen then you might not be covering
the tops of the heels of your skin enough and
i think a lot of people do run into this issue
because there are studies showing that most people
apply less than half the required amount now the
amount that you need to apply does depend on
how big your face is but a general rule that
covers pretty much everyone is a quarter teaspoon
for your face not including your ears or neck
mixing sunscreen with other products it's really
tempting to mix a sunscreen with other products
before you put it on some sunscreens have
really bad white casts so mixing it with say
foundation makes it look a bit less white when you
put it on the texture of some sunscreens also just
isn't great and so that way you can dilute
the texture and make it a bit more wearable
some of us are lazy and we just want to have one
step the problem is when you mix the sunscreen
with something else then it can interfere with
the film formation when a sunscreen is tested
it's tested on its own on bare skin and it's
really important that it forms a continuous
film so that the sunscreen can be spread
out evenly so you get even protection if
you add other stuff in there it can mess up the
microscopic structure of the sunscreen sunscreens
are emulsions they're a bit like mayonnaise if you
add too much oil or too much vinegar or too much
lecithin or whatever you can actually break
that emulsion the mayonnaise will separate and
same with sunscreens if it separates then you're
not getting that even layer so you shouldn't be
mixing sunscreens with well anything so this is
things like foundations pigment drops and oils
so if you want other products on your face as
well then apply it in layers in general it's
a good idea to wait five to ten minutes after
you've put on your sunscreen to put on extra
layers like foundation it's also a good idea to
find a sunscreen that already does what you want
so if you want to avoid a white cast then maybe
look for a chemical sunscreen if you only want
to do one step then maybe look for a tinted
sunscreen that isn't too tinted so you can
still apply the right amount if you want a product
that's more moisturizing then look for a sunscreen
that already has moisturizing ingredients
on it or look for a moisturizer with spf
leaving sunscreen in the heat with sunscreens
it's important to have the filters distributed
evenly through the whole product it's a bit like
paint the pigment needs to be evenly distributed
if it's settled out then you're not going to get
even coverage it's the same idea with sunscreens
sunscreen should be formulated so that the filters
are spread evenly in the product throughout the
whole shelf life but it does depend on storage
heat is something that's really good at making
sunscreens separate so if you go to the beach and
you keep the bottle in the sun that's not good if
you keep your sunscreen in the car you put it in
the glove box and you leave your car parked in
the sun that's also not good i know it seems like
a good idea to leave a bottle of sunscreen in the
car so you don't forget it but because of the heat
this is usually not a great idea so a better idea
would be to keep your sunscreen in your handbag
where it tends to have cooler temperatures if
you're going to the beach cover up your sunscreen
with something that reflects light so maybe a
white towel even better keep it in a cooler bag
also pay attention to the expiry date if you're
not very good at keeping your sunscreen out of the
heat then make sure you buy a new one every summer
dermarolling over products that aren't meant
to be derma rolled over so with a derma roller
you're opening up channels in your skin to let
skincare products go deeper and if they're not
meant to go deeper then this can be bad some
derma rollers have shorter needles and these
don't go as deep into your skin so they tend to
be a bit safer but most products are designed to
sit on the surface of your skin your skin is a
good barrier so a lot of the time the products
have a higher concentration so that the amount
that gets through the barrier is still effective
so you can think of it like a slow release but if
you've got these extra channels in your skin from
the needles then it's like a shortcut it's
like it suddenly all gets released at once
it's a bit like if you have an icy drink if you
drink it slowly it's really nice but if you drink
it too fast you get brain freeze or it's like
pepper if it's evenly distributed in your food
and you're eating it slowly you're getting a
little bit at once it's really nice but if you
eat a giant lump all at once it's not great i am
really into analogies today so the skin equivalent
of this is irritation the other thing that can
happen is again with the microbes if you have a
product that wasn't designed to go into your skin
maybe the preservative system wasn't designed to
be quite as good you could be introducing microbes
deeper into your skin leading to an infection
so these are some of the mistakes i've been
seeing around have you done any of these
i've definitely done a few are there any mistakes
that i've missed let me know in the comments
if you like this video click the thumbs up
and the subscribe you can also check out
my blog and follow me on instagram as well
see you next time for more beauty science